let's bring in jay bilas espn college
basketball
analyst in case you forget he was a very
good college basketball player in his
own right
jay do you remember your first
tournament game when you were at duke
yes we played in pullman washington
and stayed in moscow idaho and so it was
not not much of a uh
an introduction into the glory of the
tournament we were probably felt like we
were more quarantined and isolated than
the guys in indianapolis right now
who was the uh best player you played
against that year
that yeah dead left shrimp we we played
washington
at washington state in the second round
uh that was back before the tournament
expanded so
it was 1984 so we had a buy we didn't
play a first round game
uh we had a buy into the second round
and played played deadlift shrimp and
christian phelp and washington how did
you do
they beat us uh by one and uh johnny
dawkins got fouled on a lob
and just taken out and the referee just
looked at him like we're in washington
uh how surprised were you reaction to
duke not getting in this year
not surprised at all um i thought the
only shot they had to get to getting in
was was beating florida state and uh and
going to the semifinals of the acc
tournament
playing well there i don't think they
had to win but they had to play well
and uh and the coronavirus thing uh uh
having a player test positive took him
out of it so i wasn't surprised at all
what about the coveted contingency plans
of
what happens during the tournament when
the tournament gets started
if a team has to pull out what happens
let's say it's an elite eight or a sweet
16
what happens to that matchup they just
move the other one on so once the
tournament starts
everything's locked in if something
happens between now and then they'll
take one of the last four teams in order
when the last four teams left out
i think louisville was the first one and
they'll they'll just put them into that
slot
no matter what the seed is so if a you
know if a 16 seed goes out
uh because of virus issues and cannot
play
uh then they slot louisville in there so
a number one c is going to be gone
really
we get louisville as a 16th seed that's
not fair that's not fair
but it's just it's the only way they can
do it i mean i guess theoretically you
could you could shift up one bracket
and uh and just reseed it but it that
that way everybody has to
redo their scouting and their
preparation and all that stuff you're
just better off just sticking it to one
team rather than the whole bracket
it's kind of like a an airplane flight
like if you miss a flight
or if if they cancel a flight they don't
they don't just book everybody on the
next one and
inconvenience everybody they just didn't
confess that one flight but are you
going to have these four teams that are
sort of in the on deck circle
they're quarantining practicing ready to
go
just in case that that's yes they're
testing
uh and ready they've they had to notify
the selection committee that they're
willing to
to go if they're called i don't
anticipate that happening
uh but who knows there's a lot of things
you didn't anticipate but but you know
the conference tournaments i mean
it was some big names with virginia duke
and kansas having an issue
uh but otherwise everything went off
pretty well i think the
i think the biggest issue dan was there
was a little bit of trauma there
you know it was one year basically to
the day and all of a sudden you had
a few teams drop uh all
you know within 24 hours and it started
to feel like deja vu all over again a
little bit but but you know
intellectually you knew that this is not
that big of a deal i mean
it certainly sucks for those teams and
their fans and the coaches all that
stuff but but it wasn't
it wasn't anything going to derail you
know the the conference tournaments and
uh tv and all that stuff the business is
going to go on no matter how many people
you know have to have to bow out of this
doesn't feel like there's any outrage
today
normally the day after you know we're
railing against a team that got in or
seated too high or team that didn't get
in
uh is there any outrage no
maybe that's because we're just happy to
have it uh but the committee did a
pretty good job i mean there were some
things that that i didn't care for
but nothing where you're going really
like are you guys you know the balls
around right
we've had those in the past we didn't
have that this year so overall
i think it was pretty good and uh you
know i mean
you could core there are a couple things
i don't like that the committee does
usually and that is um i don't like it
when they put
uh mid-major against mid-major um and
because
you know one of them loses and you know
that's when you go put
any time you can put the little guy
against a big shot and let's see what
happens
because that's what people seem to want
and it is a television event after all
um and they know that too um but overall
i thought it was i thought it was pretty
good and pretty balanced that was the
the best part of it was there's no
region you're going well that one's a
bear and this one's easy
um they all seem seem pretty pretty
balanced which is
is i think the the number one thing to
do for any committee
jay bilas he has been college basketball
analyst you mentioned this is a tv show
i was wondering about this
if zion was still on duke this year and
they were 13 and 11
would would the committee look at duke
differently
if you had a marquee must-see player
like that
well that's part of the problem dan is
if zion were on duke's team they
wouldn't be thirteen
maybe twenty-four maybe twenty-three and
one okay
come on all right well that but that
that's the issue with them is they
didn't have
they didn't have superstar talent they
had they had good talent
and they were just kind of just like
everybody else this year they had good
players
and youth and all that but you know so
with kentucky and duke
you know people some people were saying
uh-huh one and done doesn't work anymore
well it works at oklahoma state and it
works at gonzaga
and it works at usc you know they just
didn't get the superstars this year
and and kentucky and duke usually do i
wonder about
you know once we get done with the one
and done
how that's going to change what the blue
bloods do recruiting wise or how that's
going to affect the mid majors
do you see a seismic shift there that
now all of a sudden
duke's getting the guy who's gonna stay
three years
maybe but they're also gonna get they'll
get the best players
uh anyway and they'll be more active in
the transfer market
um that's gonna be a bigger deal going
forward you're going to see
uh players that identify themselves as
being really good
uh are going to go well heck i can go to
duke or kentucky now uh
and that you'll see that more often but
i'm not convinced that one and done is
going away
um it it you know you may see
other avenues but um if if the ncaa
wises up
or if the supreme court says they they
have to
um players are going to be able to make
money and if they can make money college
is going to be a
pretty good option what is your
philosophy in filling out a bracket
mine is um be careful of the upsets
that you're looking for because you know
saying the 512
happens it's picking the right 512. and
this year a lot of the double-digit
upsets are going to be major conference
teams
that are are the double-digit seed
whether it's rutgers or syracuse or
michigan state or things like that those
don't seem to be as appealing
um but i i don't i look at who i think
is going to advan
the team i think that's going to advance
uh in in the bracket
and i don't worry as much about the
upsets because those are the first
weekend
fun things and you know when you start
thinking about like a uh
a 15 seed or something um two seeds are
132 and eight
against 15 seeds you know it sometimes
it seems like hey those 15
this team can really play they can play
but they don't win as often as you think
and then they don't win a second game
so when you start thinking about florida
gulf coast or something that's great
but it it's happened once and uh and you
got to be
got to be a little careful of stuff
that's only happened once gonzaga's
chances here of going undefeated um
you know obviously it hasn't happened
since 1976 but
given everything that's happened is that
on the same level as what
indiana did with bob knight yeah yeah i
think so
um you know i don't i i think
the the field is a little bit younger
now than it was back then that's the
only difference between football and
basketball the players now are better
than they've ever been so if gonzaga
played that indiana team
they'd drill them um and but but
the players were older and so that's the
only thing that would give them
more of a chance it's like if you took
you know the 1972 nebraska cornhuskers
and they played against uh alabama this
year who do you think would win
alabama drug them um but but football
hasn't changed the ages of the players
haven't changed the ages have changed in
basketball that's the only thing that
makes it where you could say okay
the teams of yesteryear uh would do
really well against the teams now is
because you'd have seniors playing
against freshmen at times
you got a surprise team that's not going
to be a surprise if you tell me what
your surprise team is
yeah i mean there are a couple um like
the upsets i see
are in the west uh before they get uh
their season shut down by gonzaga i
think both
uc santa barbara and ohio u are really
good picks there
ohio u's got a player named jason
preston as a point guard
that is the lamella ball of this
tournament um he's a triple double guy
uh he averages about 16 seven and seven
and uh really really talent he's gonna
be a first round nba draft pick and ucsb
has really good guards in addition to a
fantastic party area called isla vista
which is a wonderful place if you're
young and want to have a few beers and
enjoy yourself
isla vista is a place to go do you
remember the first time you played
against jordan
yes right absolutely um it was at a
pickup game
in chapel hill at a place called woolen
gym
and uh and we were we were the number
one ranked recruiting class and we went
over to chapel hill to play
and uh and after after playing against
you know jordan and those guys we were
kind of looking at ourselves going
i don't know if this is gonna this might
not have been a good decision
and then and then you know like people
would say hey did you
know in college that jordan was going to
be great like yeah
yeah we did we knew um you know
when you played against him and len bias
and ralph sampson
you're kind of going all right whoever
said all men are created equal
that's bs like that's just not true
i try to tell people about len bias that
like
you know he he had that explosion like
dominique wilkins type explosion there
but um but he could shoot it too yeah
he was a beautiful jump shirt he was
superman like like we used to call him
superman because we'd come back to the
huddle and one of our guys would go i'm
trying to foul him and i can't foul
did you face ewing i did in high school
i played against patrick ewing in high
school i don't know if he
well he probably remembers it not
because of of anything to do with me but
we played it in a
like this all-star event at pepperdine
in malibu and one of my teammates guy
named billy knox who played at uh saint
bernards high school
and then went to saint mary's shattered
a backboard in uh in warm-ups
and so that was uh and then and then we
wound up playing so it was
it was fun playing against him were you
guarding him yeah yeah
yeah he had a good game i don't know if
those two things are related
i you know you know when you talk about
a force in college basketball
i loved elijah won but you know viewing
his presence and what he meant to the
game and his coach and all of those
things and
you know it's hard to describe it to
somebody unless they saw what they
experienced of what hoya paranoia was
all about
yeah hoya paranoia that part of it and
then
just how dominant he was as a player
that um you know back then the center
was was the feared position and you know
if you were a dominant center you were
the first pick in the draft
it wasn't a discussion point and that's
why elijah went number one over jordan
or sam bowie went number two you know
that would never happen today
uh but back back then it happened
routinely but when
when ewing dunked it remember in the
title game in in 82 he was goaltending
all these shots
and the announcers were going what is he
doing and and uh
john thompson do exactly he wanted to
let everybody you know he wanted ewing
to let everybody know that he was there
they did and they almost won that game i
wonder what ralph sampson would
have been like in today's game it feels
like there's a porzingis type feel to
him
he would have been just as dominant as
he was back then like people forget he
was the mvp of the all-star game in 85
he averaged 20 and 10 for a period of
years but then he got hurt
and once his it was like a thoroughbred
uh horse
having bad bad knees that's what
happened i remember
uh go i was in houston doing something
in the late 80s and i went to a game
and he was with the sacramento kings and
he couldn't run anymore
and i i was it was so sad because you
know he he was such
he was so great like he should have been
he it was like almost like walton
you know with his feet um it diminished
what he was as a pro
but both of them were hall of famers
nate smith hall of famers on their
college careers alone
uh you know two of the greatest that
have ever played i think
who did you pick to win it all
yeah gonzaga i think zag is the best
team um and gonzaga and illinois i mean
i think there's gonna be
a little bit of chaos in the in the
first weekend
but i think the the top teams are are
pretty strong the one i'm i'm
concerned about is michigan because
isaiah livers has been out
and if he's not back and then they've
got ella they probably have lsu in the
second round
uh i don't know that lsu is going to get
beat by saint bonaventure although saint
bonaventure is pretty good the fighting
wodge bombs
um but i i i think i think michigan is
the the only one
that uh that you're going oh man without
livers maybe
maybe they could trip up a little bit
thanks as always jay
uh we'll hopefully check in with you
during the tournament and uh my best to
the boys uh
there in bristol should have been dayton
last year dan yeah they would have been
a good run man i know now they're going
to the nit
i know sucks yeah i know eastern
kentucky hasn't been the same since you
left either oh my god
you know they have been not any good
not any good jay they've been consistent
thank you bud that's uh jay billis
a former uh duke great